pensemos acerca de lo que podría ocurrir
en los eeuu y al dólar se le permite
debilitarse frente al yuan ok lo más
obvio es que las importaciones chinas
serán más caras ok
las importaciones chinas serán más caras
ok máscaras y un efecto menos obvio es y
eso reduciría la demanda por
importaciones chinas o si por el
contrario va a tener algún impacto en la
inflación de eeuu la razón por la que no
es tan claro es que digamos que una
funda para tu celular en tu tienda de
celulares digamos pagas 30 dólares por
ella porque hay esos 30 dólares no es el
costo que algunos fabricantes chinos
obtienen por él en realidad el
fabricante chino estará cobrando
alrededor de 60 ó 80 centavos por dólar
para producir la funda del resto del
dinero que pagas es para los que venden
digamos los los proveedores o
esencialmente pagas por el costo de
envío de china de eeuu así esos 60
centavos que era lo que costaba
realmente en china
y esto digamos y ahora sube a 80
centavos o a un dólar no es claro si si
no es claro si si el precio tiene que
cambiar o si fuera cambiar a 30 oa 31 no
es claro si eso afectaría la demanda
ahora hacia el impacto que este
debilitamiento del dólar tuviera en la
inflación es que la idea que todas las
importaciones se volverán más caras
verdad
todas las importaciones se volverán más
caras potencialmente esto impactaría en
como otros países reaccionen frente al
dólar pero todas las importaciones
bueno realmente la importación más
importante y nuevamente esto depende de
cómo estas monedas reaccionen a la
producción de petróleo que los
productores de petróleo
digamos manipulen el precio respecto al
dólar así que podrían no ser tan
dramático como uno piensa pero en
general cuando tienes al dólar
debilitándose lo más importante desde un
punto de vista estadounidense es la
importación más importante de todas
probablemente estará en el margen de
volverse más cara y estamos hablando del
petróleo también tenemos potencialmente
un comprador menos afuera y motivando
tanto o bueno motivando tanto comprando
directamente o motivando a otros países
para comprar así que la deuda podría
volverse más cara que la deuda podría
volverse más cara en los eeuu cuando
digo que la deuda se vuelve más cara es
que las tasas de interés crezcan por
supuesto esto depende mucho de como la
reserva federal intervenga o podría lo
mejor continuar imprimiendo más dinero
para mantener barato el crédito que
tampoco parece ser tan bueno ahora la
última y probablemente la más importante
pregunta es en cierto grado otra vez no
es
pero qué le pasa a los fabricantes
americanos
el argumento ha sido que esencialmente
china ha sido capaz de producir de forma
más barata que lo que hubieran
naturalmente podido producir así que
gracias a que su moneda estaba barata
eso esencialmente roba la base
industrial de los estados unidos
regresar a esto o algo de esto regresará
de china o de otros países ok
es cierto que el dólar más débil en eeuu
ayudará a las exportaciones de eeuu lo
que es menos claro si las industrias que
son dependientes de la mano de obra y
requieren quizás una gran habilidad será
que ellas regresen de asia y sospecho
como dije en el vídeo de china que se
van a quedar en asia o en donde les sea
más fácil moverse en lugares más
naturales para ir mientras tengan la
mano de obra barata y bajen sus
estándares de vivienda
por ahora verdad
ok puede ser latinoamérica puede ser
india puede ser no sé varios lugares
pero bueno y ahí tienen lo que
necesitaría para competir con china en
particular es esencialmente tener la
infraestructura para ello los sistemas
de eficiencia escala para competir
efectivamente así que este es
probablemente digamos la gente de la que
china tiene que preocuparse más y
revalorizan su moneda no tanto los eeuu
aunque ayudará a mantener la manufactura
de estados unidos al margen para tener
una moneda más débil reportando de lacan
academy para la cnv s